you
[Music]
so hello I'm Jeff Arnold
so formerly of inside day science is a
day science fellow and we'll be working
at instacart beginning of January is a
day scientist so I should get used to
saying things like my opinions do not
necessarily represent the opinions of
anyone who has or ever will employ me
probably don't represent the opinions of
myself in the past toward the future so
this is a bit of a click Beatty title I
realize after the fact if you're parsing
it as solving our for data science I'm
not going to do that most of the people
here are doing that far better than I so
I will give you time to leave if you're
expecting me to solve our for all of
data science instead I am solving our
for data science as in our for data
science which needs no introduction by
wickham enrollment and I made exercise
solutions to it and that's what I'm
going to be discussing so hopefully
that's not too much of a letdown so as
one would expect these are a set of
exercise solutions to all exercises and
are for data science it is up on github
as one is want to do and it is all in
done with book down and compiled to a
nice pretty website but why did I write
these solutions what was I thinking at
the time and I'd go back to and reflect
upon it but the main thing was this was
from my previous life as an academic so
I was using our for day science in the
course I was responsible for teaching
kind of the first year sequence of
quantitative methods to social science
PhD students at least with the students
I had I really couldn't assume any sort
of prior statistical experience
nor any prior programming experience and
they were interested in that need to do
applied research not in the theory
behind it necessarily except to the
extent that it moves that forward which
is actually kind of perfect because
really like this book in the sense that
it's not a book about our as a
programming language per se nor is it a
book a book about statistics that
happens to use are on the side it really
starts with getting people into using
our to get their job done and you know
at least when I took quantitative
methods courses it was a lot of this I
know a lot of people here are improving
that curricula and so I don't expect
this to be the case much longer but you
know in practice and you know most
Applied Research is a lot more like this
you know there's the importing the
tidying the transforming the visualizing
the modeling and of that modeling the
like proofs behind why all that
statistical inference works is a very
small sliver of it a very important
sliver one that we can not ignore but
you have to go through a lot of stuff
just to get there and that's why I
adopted this textbook that was great you
know now I could spend more time working
with the students and less time writing
more and more the same material but you
know as a new book so I was like well I
should probably see what's in it if I'm
going to assign it and so I just kind of
sat down and worked through it I knew
tied to verse so it was it was fine and
then you know put it up on github and I
didn't want to make it too obvious that
it was our for data science and so you
know I took the rot13 of it and called
it a 4qf I clearly not too good with the
cryptography so there's these things
called search and apparently people
found it
and so yeah so that's really how it got
there and so all this happened about
like the month before actually I think
are four days science was even published
I think I signed it prior to the
official publication date did that put
it up there you know told my students
they could look at it it was great the
clearly didn't catch enough typos as I
found out later and then it just kind of
sat around there until eventually people
started finding it so what did I learn
from this experience well I mean I would
like to be able to say that like you
know experience of being a beginner and
working through and learning it I don't
want to say I suffer from expert bias in
this because I'm not really an expert
but I didn't get that part of it you
know so if one is wondering this is the
thread where the the closure name came
from so I had a bit of experience with
tight diverse as mostly I learned a lot
through those books but I found most of
stuff in practice I ended up learning
from all of it is one you know if you
put stuff on github and make it public
some people might find it useful and
that's really what happened here
second I make lots of typos so I spent a
lot of time kind of technical fixes to
that because I didn't want to go back
and proofread everything and I've been
using this kind of opportunity learn new
things so when you know new markdown
stuff comes up I try it out if I want to
learn some more JavaScript or some other
sort of new technology I test it out
here
so first thing to do like I go end up
building up a lot of automation in terms
of deployment of this you know it uses
book down to build it Travis commits it
and deploys it to github pages but then
I go through a lot of different things
of check the spelling using our open
side spelling package winter styler and
a lot of extra stuff like I've went the
markdown I checked the HTML I checked
for all the broken links this can be
kind of quite useful I here's one that
came up yesterday or so the HTML winter
found that the idea of something
generated by HTML widgets was a
duplicate so there would have been a
double image in there that I would never
found and I picked it up and you know
removed the caching and fix it after a
bit of annoyance but this is something
that picked up so been building up that
over time same sort of thing after it's
built check all the links all 16,000 of
them to make sure that they're still
working this picks up things like you
know spelling exercises wrong or whatnot
a second thing I'd like to do is trying
to like reduce friction and getting user
feedback so you know it's been helpful
has that put it up people found it and I
just kind of responded as people brought
up things so this is one of my favorite
ones
the question is brainstorm as many ways
as possible to select depth time depth
delay our time and our array from flight
so a bunch of different ways to do the
Select command I was all clever I
mentioned the numbers and then I say
things like this is bad it's obfuscated
what do these columns mean I don't know
what column six is I just wrote the code
and I've already forgotten I'm sure
enough I get a issue raised that I
actually brought in the wrong column
after writing that and it was not on
purpose I'm not that clever but people
catch that sort of stuff and I think
that's great and you know had some
people contribute in various ways I
would like I love more contributions and
but one thing with github issues is just
kind of how time-consuming they are so
these are a broad bunch from Greg Wilson
which are literally things like and a
whole bunch of just
or typos as I said I make lots of typos
opening up a github issue for all of
those is kind of annoying so I also
tried putting on the service hypothesis
which allows annotation of websites so
that's pretty nice and that it's a lot
easier just to highlight something then
leave a comment and say this is
misspelled this is a typo rather than
opening up a github issue you know some
places you do want that extra friction
for feedback I think it with these sort
of things you want less friction but
then I started thinking another way to
go forward with it is simply to write
something where you can just highlight
the text and then it will open up a new
github issue that has that highlighted
text is the body of the issue and you
know links to the page where that's
occurring so in something like a
document that makes things a lot easier
to submit these sort of kind of minor
trivial there's a typo here type issues
another thing I started looking at here
was what could I learn from user
behavior so there's Google Analytics on
it as of November when I started playing
around with it and so kind of thought
I'd throw that information in and see
what are the page views of people on
these various the various chapters of
are for data science solutions so the
top are the highest chapters going from
like the first couple intros and you see
data visualization has lots of page
views then transformations have a little
less and it kind of decreases rapidly as
one would expect in that sort of
behavior but can we maybe say something
about which ones seem to be harder or
which people are which ones people are
turning to and one problem with that is
the number of exercises in or for day
signs vary dramatically with these
chapter okay so day visualization
transformation also have lot of
exercises strings has a ton of exercises
but let's go ahead and put
they're a simple statistical model a
model use unique users meaning the page
as a function of chapter and exercises
and then look for pages that are not
explained well by it as being
potentially very hard or very easy or
ones that people want to view otherwise
and we see that like exploratory data
analysis the third major chapter seems
to be receiving fewer page users and
expected people seem to tail off at the
end but iteration and the beginning of
the modeling chapters seem to get lots
of users even given how far into the
book they are and the number of
exercises they have so with that I kind
of wanna know you know what's next with
this and basically I really only had one
goal here just saying that like this
solutions exists there up on github
they're there for people to contribute
I'm not trying to keep this my own I
love everyone to if you see something
wrong if you see ways it can be improved
contribute edit I'd love to open this up
as much as possible those are the links
to it and that's my information
[Applause]
thank you we have a few minutes for
questions we have a few mics we have the
thurible mics like we had in the opening
keynote not one over here hello it is
this way
um hey Jeff I was I really appreciated
the infrastructure that you put together
around like testing the HTML mm-hmm um
and stuff like that like I'd really like
to implement that there's some things
that I've done have you written anywhere
about like a way to do that or a guide
or something um I have not written a
guide to do that and it's kind of a lot
of this has just evolved as I've tried
things out you can check out the source
code of it
one thing I've tended to use at least
where the HTML and markdown has been
actually to turn to node in JavaScript
packages just because there's so much
web infrastructure there seem to be
easier to implement but but that's about
all I have there but I I'll think about
writing up more on that so which book
you doing next I don't know
[Laughter]
the one thing I didn't get to which I
would love to ask Hadley at some point
was what does the deal with the nursery
rhymes
I know started with you know little
bunny foo foo but then there's like
multiple exercises in our for data
science about implementing nursery
rhymes and other songs in my memory it
was like pages of these in reality
there's only three questions but I
didn't I should since I had time I
should have put it in there but for what
it's worth the baby shark song seems to
be one that would fall under that rubric
very well I if they threw this back up I
have a very nice version that uses math
in there you can like turn nested
for-loops into multiple intervals so
that might be the next song to become an
hour programming teaching tool
you
[Music]